[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans la grande
interview avec cette semaine emmanuel
hussenet merci de nous consacrer ce
moment vous êtes explorateurs et je dois
dire que pour un explorateur un voyageur
d'avoir passé plus de deux mois comme ça
confine est enfermé chez lui parce que
j'imagine que vous avez été enfermé chez
vous ça lui est insupportable non c'est
vrai c'est paradoxalement c'est à la
fois complètement insupportable je
dirais dans le principe mais en pratique
c'est tout à fait une habitude comprends
qu'on organise ce genre de voyages me
voyagent dans les régions polaires donc
évidemment quand il ya une tempête on
est cloîtrée sous la tente
immobilisé pendant des jours pas pendant
deux mois au bout de quelques jours au
bout d'un moment on oublie de sortir
mais on a l'habitude de d'une forme
d'isolement
en revanche en france dans ces mêmes
conditions d'isolement si je te fais
autre chose ça beaucoup ça pose beaucoup
de questions en matière de liberté
évidemment on va on va y revenir un
petit peu bien que la france sait que
les français soient soit libéré
maintenant de de cette contrainte je
disais vous être explorateurs sais pas
si vous aimez ce ce titre mais ça fait
toujours rêver les enfants et nous
sommes restés des grands enfants vous
vous êtes écrivain aussi et vous
raconter finalement au voyage pour le
transmettre de transmettre aux autres
oui c'est vrai aujourd'hui je sais pas
très bien ce que signifie l'exploration
à l'âge de google earth
en tout cas il ya énormément de
territoire encore aujourd'hui on ne va
jamais on en parle mais c'est comme les
glaces glace beaucoup fantasmé avec le
climat on entend parler paix de banquise
que de ce que deux glaciers sans faire
forcément la différence en revanche se
rendre sur place dans le nord du
groenland dans le nord du canada en
terre délaisse mais en termes d bafin au
doigt sur le loup l'île du spitzberg
c'est tout à fait autre chose on se
retrouve là face à une réalité qu'une
réalité physique est une réalité
naturelle qui est beaucoup plus
puissante que nous et on n'a pas
l'habitude de ce rapport de force
inversée auquel on est habitué nous ici
évidemment l'homme est puissant il
dirige tout il dirige même en ce qui ce
qui se passe actuellement en fait ils
décident de sa propre vie de sa mort
mais là bas ça se passe tout à fait
autrement on est dans une autre
dimension et ça fait du bien je dirais
ça fait du bien et c'est tout ce que
vous avez vous avez raconté un ca dans
des livres dont vous avez quand même
publié pas mal de deux livres je vais
rappeler simplement les les derniers là
le testament des glaces c'était en 2008
mais on se souvient du regard que vous
portez sur la disparition des banquises
aimez vous joignez votre voix à un
certain nombre aux autres experts
scientifiques pour dénoncer justement et
la fonte des glaces liée au
réchauffement climatique robinsons des
glaces une aventure pour sauver la
planète
alors là l'engagement est encore plus
forte 2017 et puis là vous raconter
dernièrement la légion des pôles
c'était en novembre 2019
parce que ces pôles avant de parler de
l'actualité
ils ont une histoire ils ont surtout des
mythes
ils ont une légion c'est très curieux
avant de vous de vous rencontrer
j'ai fait l'expérience auprès de d'une
dizaine de personnes des amis ce
week-end ou est-ce que tu aimerais
passait des vacances
alors les uns disent les maldives les
autres des seychelles
j'en ai pas un qui m'a dit j'aurais aimé
aller suer au pôle nord au pôle sud
comme qu'est ce qui fait que les pôles
ont ce pouvoir en revanche c'est très
attractif
c'est très attractif et très attirant
qu'est ce que tu veux vous expliquer ça
on fait les gens ils vont quand même
mais à bord de bateaux de croisière
aujourd'hui de façon à prendre le
maximum de sécurité dans leurs démarches
mais mais le fait est que les pôles
fascine évidemment ça fascine
complètement mais en même temps il ya
une peur qui s'installe on a une peur
physique traité régions froides en a
peur du froid on a peur de beaucoup de
choses de l' isolement même des ours
puisqu'ils encore des ours là bas donc
je pense que ça ça qu'une certaine on
entretient une certaine une sorte de
mythologie mais dont on a du mal à se
rapprocher je pense que c'est un peu le
même problème avec l'histoire du
réchauffement climatique puisque je
m'engageais beaucoup dans cette
direction là on entend on en entend
parler de façon assez abstraite alors
que concrètement cela se traduit par pas
grand chose hormis d été et il faut dire
un peu de plus en plus chaud est de plus
en plus sec desprats
très sec comme on observait encore cette
année donc face à cette situation
globale parce que c'est une situation
globale la fonte des glaces etc
hypothèque est l'avenir de l'humanité de
façon très sérieuse en imagine la
plupart des scientifiques imaginent qu à
partir de 2050 on franchira un point de
non retour c'est à dire les banquise
pluriannuelle qui recouvre l'océan
glacial arctique en permanence auront
fondu
donc il n'y la terre va perdre si vous
voulez son climatiseur ce qui permettait
nous aujourd'hui dans l'hémisphère nord
les missions boréale en tout cas de la
terre d'avoir des étés relativement
tempéré
grâce à ces glaces permanentes des
glaces de mer six classes de mer vont
disparaître j'ai tout fait je pense à
mon échelle à ma mesure pour essayer
d'en parler mais évidemment on n'en
verse pas la marche du monde si vous
voulez on va pas décider d'un coup de
plus prendre l'avion de plus de rouler
10 fois moins et est de rester chez soi
mais horse à 10h constance qu'on ne
cesse vient de se produire donc ce n'est
pas la bonne volonté de protéger de la
planète lui mais l'avenir de l'humanité
qui a permis cela mais un petit virus
qui a permis cet arrêt momentané de
l'économie tels que ce serait souhaitée
je dirais par les écologistes idéalement
pour réduire les émissions de carbone
alors on va envahir venir tout de suite
mais quand vous dites tout ce que vous
dites sur l'épaule vous savez que vous
participer finalement à la légende de
ces pôles en dix ans mais ils sont comme
ça on vous passez vous parler au futur
et on n'y peut rien mais vous participez
à la légion qui avait écrit qu avait
commencé à écrire virgile dans
l'antiquité
jules verne aussi et même victor hugo
donc vous vous ajoutez du mystère au
mystère et à cette fête
la question que je me pose dans le
dernier livre s'appelle la légende des
pôles c'est de savoir comment on peut
encore écrire aujourd'hui une mythologie
enfin un rêve comment peut-il s'inscrire
un rêve autour du pôle aujourd'hui
savais que c'était fallait depuis
l'antiquité les grecs savez connaissait
l'existence des poules mais c'étaient
des endroits on savait qu'on ne pouvait
pas les atteindre à cause du froid à
cause du clip jour permanent ni
permanente et tout cela donc c'était ça
le reste est tout à fait inconnu alors
que géographiquement s'était
parfaitement connue donc longtemps vous
interrogez mais y at-il là bas
il ya eu la mythologie des licornes
affectés dans la dent narval différentes
mythologies mais marc casse pattes
l'histoire du septentrion chez les grecs
l'hyper boré et quel monde et grec s'il
dit à beaucoup de dhimmi lithologies
autour du nord jusqu'à jules verne qui
voulait absolument imaginer qu'il y
avait une sorte de maelström de
tourbillon dangereux qui a emporté les
navires là-bas ou qu'il pouvait y avoir
ou en antarctique aussi un océan avec un
gouffre comme l'avait imaginé aussi
edgar poe en fait également george sand
qui a écrit sur l'épaule qui a imaginé
que c'était fait l'entrée d'une usine
géo géantes qui à l'intérieur de la
terre en fait c'était l'ouverture qui
permettait d'entrer d'explorer
l'intérieur de la terre se trouvait au
pôle nord don kelly envoie ses
personnages donc il ya cette mythologie
alors aujourd'hui qu'elle mythologie
peut encore se greffer je crois que la
mythologie le plus importante
aujourd'hui c'est celle d'une forme de
retour à la nature ou de d'harmonie
perdu dans la relation entre l'homme et
la nature sauvage qui est encore
totalement brut
alors on imagine week les glaçons en
danger on peut dire ça c'est par les
cirques en particulier des glaces de mer
mais il ya encore beaucoup beaucoup
d'épaisseur de glace au groenland à sur
la ligne 26 à quelle place hier il y
avait que ce fameux réchauffement comme
les glaciers avancent plus vite il se
délite davantage
donc lorsqu'on navigue dans les fjords
le long de la côte est du groenland de
l'ouest mais aussi du sud vient on est
souvent embêté avec un débat tout à
cause de la l'abondance de glace qui
assure la mère donc tous font mais quand
on va là-bas on observe qu'en définitive
il ya plus de glace c'est parce que
justement ça font donc ce qu'on observe
n'est pas représentatif de cette réalité
qui est extrêmement fragile et qui nous
échappe encore en grande partie bob
votre passion avoue c'est l'article c
est à dire le pôle nord c'est surtout
l'article parce qu'il était assis dans
le bus la wii vous savez l'entendez
cliquer l'antarctique c'est assez sharon
aussi je dirais mais il est beaucoup
plus froid déjà plus massif et y accéder
est plus difficile parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'aéroport en antarctique il faut passer
par un bateau faut souvent passer par
des moyens nationaux va pas parler taf
par le ministère a cédé fois de
scientifiques voilà
alors que l'arctique c'est quand même
peuple est depuis toujours depuis au
moins 4000 ans avec les inuit et il ya
quelques aérodrome disséminés à très
hautes latitudes on en trouve jusqu'à 80
degrés de tic nord agnelli soon par
exemple au spitzberg ou a résolu tu l'as
été un peu plus au sud dans le centre du
canada ou au groenland à canach non
extrême nord ouest du groenland dans la
région qu'on appelle la région de tulle
et cher à jean paul ii le vous vous y
est vous y arrive vous y avez accès dès
la première fois en canot et en kayak
oui en se faisant déjà déposé par un
avion sur place mais c'est vrai que là
bas ce sont des pays sans route donc le
seul déplacement possible ces abcès ou
soir-là pieds soit par voie maritime
ce sont des régions qui sont peuplées
par les inuit initialement ce sont des
peuples marins y circule de l'eau le
long des mères avec les umiak pour
transporter leurs familles et les kaya
qui sont les embarcations de chasse donc
nous on imite appelé les kayaks on les
rayons x en mer comme ils sont ils sont
nés en mer ces fameux que les yacks et
de cette façon on peut se déplacer dans
les fjords descendance et relief
extrêmement découpé et au demeurant eux
au style des côtes du groenland ou de
toutes les rivages la maire de batz fin
des grandes l'arctique canadien et ou du
spitzberg et c'est comme ça qu'on a qu'à
une certaine forme de liberté mais une
liberté hors du temps hors du temps
d'ici parce que nous comme il n'y a pas
de route faut faire 60 km est à peu près
un jour et demi
voilà j'aurais aimé une navigation
parfois deux jours ou plus en fonction
de la météo de ce que vous savez de ce
qui s'est passé là-bas est ce que est ce
que vos amis ont rencontré le virus là
bas est ce que le virus le coroner est
allé jusqu'au pôle nord
je crois pas je pense qu'ils ont
d'autres soucis que le virus
intellectuelle dans l'idée il a franchi
toutes les frontières il a même atteint
le pôle nord voilà où la peur qu'on peut
en avoir été présente pour revenir à
leurs propres préoccupations
nous savons que vous êtes à l'origine
d'un projet qui s'appelle en
universalise du nom d'un de d'unilin qui
s'appelle en ski est un rocher en fait
sa recherche
r à partir duquel vous voudriez que les
scientifiques l'occupent quelque part
pour pour retenir les bâtisses qui
dérive parce que c'est celle là c'est un
marqueur oui c'est un projet très
ambitieux chanteuse pose considéré
aujourd'hui qu'il a échoué parce que je
pense que le monde aussi à d'autres
préoccupations
mais qui repose sur un différend
territorial entre le canada et le
danemark et qui revendiquent chacun une
île qui se trouve exactement à 1000 km
du pôle nord géographique c'est très
très très au nord et une zone totalement
inhabitée et inhabitables et c'est un
rocher d'un kilomètre carré à peu près
mais ils se bagarrent pour des questions
de territoriale et puis c'est les sept
îles au milieu d'un passage qui permet
d'accéder à l'océan glacial arctique
dont quand elle est là seront terminés
de fond dont on imagine que des routes
commerciales pour vous ouvrir de ce côté
là donc l'idée c'était de faire un
territoire neutre c'est-à-dire de
suspendre ses revendications qui sont à
la fois des phrases qui sont toujours
sisters en définitive des revendications
de lego moi je sais pour moi je vais
plus fort que le voisin et je pense que
je pense que tous constaté cela que si
on continue de raisonner comme cela
c'est sûr qu'il ya l'humain sera guère
d'avenir parce que si on cherche à
chacun ira à obtenir le maximum
davantage du peu qu'il reste de cette
pauvre nature et bien il restera encore
mois et d'ici peu très peu de temps donc
c'était pour en verser 7 7
c'était pourtant essayé de tenter de
créer une diplomatie de l'intérêt commun
à travers l'exemple de cette île alors
ça va nous ramener à l'accueil en en
faisant un territoire
universal va nous ramener un peu à
l'actualité vous avez dit a pas très
longtemps
ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup plus que le
virus c'est la peur que nous en avons
expliqué moi parce que là là on est dans
le subjectif
oui on est complètement dans le
subjectif mais je pense que le virus est
très subjectif aussi bon il a une
objectivité évidemment cela dit effacés
c'est pas la peste non plus
ni la malaria c'est donc on construit
une réaction en fonction d'un élément
objectif métiers subjective et
évidemment dès lors qu'il se transforme
en décisions politiques et qui se dé
transforme en mode horn en mots d'ordre
qui fait abstraction de des libertés
fondamentales de l'individu on n'a plus
le droit de sortir de chez soi afin de
façon très mesurée très content et comme
si on était en résidence surveillée
c'est une situation qui est inédite dans
l'histoire de l'europe du monde et de
l'histoire de france est ce à l'échelle
nationale intel intel l'interdiction
n'existe pas même en temps de guerre
donc déjà se l'imaginer ce n'était pas
facile je pense que les premières
semaines la plupart d'entre nous avons
arrêté dans une sorte d'état de
sidération sous le choc on imagine les
pas qu une simple menace sanitaire alors
qu'on sait que ça peut arriver pouvait
réduire à nous obliger obliger tout le
monde à cesser toutes affaires cessantes
toute activité et ça je pense que ça
pose des questions fondamentales parce
qu'on peut on peut appliquer des mesures
sanitaires
mais si cette mesure sanitaire signifie
systématiquement supprimés des libertés
fondamentales liberté de la convivialité
ne serait-ce que de partager un verre la
liberté de se déplacer de se marier et
d'enterrer des fins et c'est ça du jour
au lendemain je pense que ça pose
forcément des questions et j'étais assez
surpris par la facilité avec lesquels
nous on est moi j'en fais partie avec
laquelle on à n'accepter ces nouvelles
conditions qu'il faut qu'on fait qu'on
doit se déplacer sous conditions et ça
c'est ça c'est inquiétant et je pense
que la peur c'est quelque chose de très
subjectif et évidemment lorsque je parle
quand je parle même un petit comité à 3
ou 4 ou bien seul dans ces régions là il
ya une peur qui est permanente qui est
liée en particulier à la présence de
l'ours polaire qui est l'un des derniers
grands prédateurs qui est susceptible de
s'en prendre directement à l'homme
plus la peur des changements de météo
qui sont encore plus redoutable on est
dans un environnement extrêmement
précaire surtout lorsqu'on installe sa
tente sur une plaque de banquise
flottante s'amuser à faire avec les
robinsons des glaces donc la peur on vit
avec et on l'acceptent et c'est à dire
que la peur n'empêche pas de vivre c'est
à dire qu'il ya plus important que le
risque de mourir c'est le projet de vie
qu'on a chacun de nous que chacun de
nous cultive la toussaint projet de vie
une certaine idée de la vie c'est bien
normal annuler la liste et il y avait il
y avait le risque de mettre la planète
toute entière en faillite économique et
sociale c'est à dire que on a pour la
première fois dans l'histoire
l'ensemble des gouvernements après la
décision de prendre ce risque là pour
sauver des vies humaines
oui mais je sais pas s'il mesure est
bien ce risque je sais pas si c'est
cette décision a été suffisamment
réfléchi ce qu'on peut savoir ce que
cette décision a été prise sur l'avis
des médecins qui est évidemment débordés
voilà on peut facilement l'imaginer mais
il n'ya pas que je dire que dans dance
sur terre et il ya aussi d'autres voix
qui mérite d'être entendu et il ya aussi
vais peut-être aussi les tout simplement
les restaurateurs les gens qui
travaillent dans le tourisme et gia
benyahia je pense qu'il ya des façons de
considérer les choses qui peuvent
permettre aussi de respecter le droit
que nous avons de travail et le droit de
vivre et ce qui est assez intéressant
aussi dans cette privatisation
généralisée
c'est ce qu'on a supprimé ce qui fait la
plus value de la vie alors faut renoncer
à vivre pour sauver des vies c'est ça le
paradoxe très souvent dans l'histoire on
nous a appris que parfois il fallait se
sacrifier il fallait on savait que
pendant l'appel la période de la
résistance beaucoup ont été assassinés
et parce qu'il tenait à la liberté par
dessus tout donc c'est cette notion de
liberté pour laquelle on se bat
finalement elle est plus très importante
c'est georges bernanos qui écrivait la
liberté pour quoi faire
et finalement cette affaire nous cette
petite histoire du covin nous raconte
que la liberté c'est pas si important
que ça on se plombe on peut la perdre
à la moindre alerte sanitaire je dirais
là c'est le discours que vous tenez il
est un peu provocant vis-à-vis de tous
vos amis experts ou écologique puis à
l'écologiste par exemple type eux ont vu
dans cette pandémie le signal d'un excès
de capitalisme d'un excès de
mondialisation et que finalement que la
planète se soit arrêté c'est pas si mal
pour arrêter aussi la diffusion de gaz
carbonique un dossier notamment mais je
le dirai de choses je pense que c'est
intéressant d'avoir aussi des points de
vue subversif voilà qui ne sont faux pas
dans le sens de ce cd côté sanitaire
contre nous imposant permanente et la
raison c'est ça pour moi la raison ce
n'est pas cela voilà j'ai encore la
liberté de le penser en ce qui concerne
votre votre marque est très judicieuse
oui par rapport aux écologistes
oui mais malheureusement je pense que
c'est un faux espoir pour eux et pour
moi aussi parce que finalement de voir
le monde a un peu qui s'arrête à ça ça
fait du bien certaine façon ça paie ça
fait un peu sourire que c'est quand même
ce monde là qui est qui qui va vers vers
un écueil qui se tire une balle dans le
pied
voilà donc il est encore plus en
difficulté mais pour sortir de cette
difficulté
une fois le des confinement installé et
on sait si là c'est en train de se
passer actuellement
eh bien il va abonder dans tout ce qui a
été fait défaut jusqu'à présent je ne
crois pas à une remise en question des
fondamentaux de notre façon de vivre
bien au contraire on va relancer la
consommation pour faire redémarrer
l'économie
donc ce petit peut-être petite période
dans laquelle honda certains ont pu
souffler une certaine façon n'est qu'un
répit assez bref et qu'il ne change rien
dans le fond voilà ce que je pense en
tout cas ça veut dire que dans votre
dans votre raisonnement dans vos
observations la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique passe par
d'autres remèdes que la décroissance
si je pense que la décroissance est
indispensable même est ce qu'on vient de
vivre ce n'est pas de la décroissance
c'est un accident au dans le parcours de
la croissance voilà tout d'un coup ça
s'est affaissé
ça va s'affaisser quelques mois encore
que sur toute l'année et après ça va
reprendre sur la même logique pourquoi
parce qu'il n'ya pas de pensée est
derrière
il ya un ordre autoritaire qui a été
imposée parce que le gouvernement un
petit peu paniqué voilà il fait ça s'est
passé de cette façon tant pis on va pas
revenir de suivre pas forcément engager
des procès enfin j'en sais rien certains
leur préparant vraisemblablement mais
toujours est il que dans le fond rien ne
changera parce qu'aucune question de
fond n'a été posée il ya pas j'ai pas
entendu une remise en question du
système productiviste dans lequel on vit
hormis ceux qui gèrent le remettre en
question fondamentalement est depuis
toujours en vain je dirais ils ont bon
marché pour le climat le monde marche
toujours dans la même direction
donc pour qu'il y ait un véritable
changement je pense personnellement et
c'est ce qu'on vient d'observer en ce
moment même qu'il faut impérativement un
agent extérieur qui n'appartiennent pas
à la raison humaine quoi qu'il dépasse
la volonté humaine un accident ce virus
était le stream est pas prévu fin dans
le virus comme la pandémie si les
risques est numéro un pour le lot et
metz depuis toujours donc on aurait pu
prévoir ça depuis très très longtemps et
mais c'est quelque chose qui est
extérieur à la volonté humaine qui vient
s'imposer au système monde tel qu'il y a
que ça à mon avis qui peut changer les
choses
c'est quoi la clé que vous avez qui
c'est quoi la clé l'équation que vous
avez pour conjuguer l'impératif
écologique ce que vous défendez et la
contrainte économique que l'ancien des
populations défendre et bien c'est cher
monsieur je n'ai pas de clé ça serait
trop beau ce serait très bien d'avoir un
messi qui a toutes les solutions non je
n'ai pas tué je pense qu on est dans une
forme d'impasse qui n'a pas n'a pas
culturel civilisationnel
on est dans un groupe bout de course on
a consommé beaucoup la terre on a encore
beaucoup de pétrole en ce moment là n'en
a plus pour très longtemps
l'électricité ne remplace pas le pétrole
non plus donc l'électricité dite verte
ne change pas grand-chose à l'équation
énergétique globale en définitive c'est
ce que beaucoup d'experts mettent en
évidence aujourd'hui on est face à un
vrai casse-tête la technologie la
technologie la technologie la science
l'intelligence humaine c'est jusqu'à
presse et pas c'est pas la clique
l'annoncé jusqu'à présent c'est ce que
nous a mis en difficulté la technologie
la science et l'intelligence humaine
comme quoi l'intelligence humaine a ses
limites
la technologie aussi il ya vous savez je
reviens sur mes expériences comparé dans
ces régions là on accepte d'abandonner
la technologie on accepte d'en prendre
une et peut-être aussi une part de son
intelligence pour laisser parler son
intuition
on accepte aussi beaucoup d'écouté la
première la chose la plus importante
le moment le plus important de la
journée c'est quand on se réveille le
matin dans son sac de couchage ce moment
on garde un petit peu sa chaleur avec
soi parce qu'on leur a pas encore
longtemps dès lors qu'on va se lever
évidemment on va être exposé au froid
eh bien on écoute on écoute le selon le
bruit qui assure la tente c'est ça
détermine de la force du vent et ouais
donc cette écoute de l'environnement
permet de s'adapter à des paramètres
physiques
or on est dans une civilisation qui est
auto référentiel ce qui fait qu'elle ne
se réfère pas à la physique elle ne se
réfèrent pas aux limites terrestre
souligne je préfère pas aux règles
naturel donc évidemment elle a tout faux
donc moi je n'ai pas la solution d'un
d'un problème où tous les paramètres
sont déjà faussé
fondamentalement nous vivons déjà hors
sol voilà ce que je veux dire donc la
seule pour moi la seule donc vous
revenez
voilà vous revenez à ma réflexion du
début vous êtes des producteurs de rêve
oui oui vous êtes des consommateurs de
rêve et puis par par ricochet vous êtes
producteur pascal parce qu'en fait la
seule répondre à votre question c'est de
se dire faut retourner retrouver un lien
avec la nature
pas forcément nécessaire d'aller au pôle
nord commente dans son jardin est juste
une parenthèse par rapport à cela tout
au début je ne permettait juste une
remarque c'est que la france au cours de
cette crise du coc vide a été divisé en
deux il ya les français qui ont un
jardin et ceux qui n'en n'ont pas donc
on dit sitifis les français qui ont
bénéficié du soleil printanier parce
qu'il s'est mis à faire beau juste au
moment de tous du sang fermé et qui ont
pu finalement survivre mieux parce qu'il
était en contact avec un minimum de
nature avec quelques armes ils
entendaient les oiseaux et s'assit
salutaire et ça c'est important
et d'autres qui n'ont pas eu cette
chance et la vraie richesse c'est
peut-être ça aujourd'hui c'est
simplement d'avoir un bout de jardin
même si on habite
de loin des grandes métropoles ça ça
pose aussi ce type de questions ça peut
peut-être préparer à une autre forme de
répartition d'occupation du territoire
est revalorisé des territoires qui ont
été délaissés yahia une dernière
question parce qu'il faut que il faut qu
il faut qu'on termine 6e cas des jeunes
qui nous regardent et qui se dit mais
comment devient explorateurs c'est une
question qu'on doit vous poser sa
suivant comment devient on rageur il ya
une école pour faire l'orateur je
voudrais répondre très clairement
j'aurais été en situation à l'âge de 15
16 ans dans cette situation où devront
être enfermés dans un appartement en
famille
je pense que j'aurais craqué et que je
me serais baril a pris un sac à dos des
chaussures de marque et je me serais
baril à travers la campagne et être
viennent que pour et je pense que pour
devenir explorateur faut avoir cet état
d'esprit c'est à dire qu'il ya un moment
où le désir de vivre le désir de liberté
est plus fort que toutes les peurs et
quand on a ce désir de vivre ce désir de
liberté on ici on est aussi responsable
moi je suis guide de métier dont on ne
peut pas dire que je suis pas
responsable des autres parce que j'ai
ramené tout le monde vivant je crois
donc on prend en respect de sa propre
vie en main mais aussi on est
respectueux des autres on va se balader
dans la nature comprend les risques
physiques en montagne ou en mer on les
prend pour soi on n'expose pas les
autres et je pense que cette liberté
on doit pas y toucher parce qu'elle est
essentielle elle caractérise notre
identité humaine et même le luxe des
libertés vous emmène où là il vous
conduit où vous partez la pression'' man
up pour le moment là je pars pas trop
parce que ça temps de voir ce qui se
passe mais c'est surtout que là il ya un
âge pour tout aussi comme roman ou de
ses expéditions polaires
voilà nom ne dit pas ça ne dit pas
ouvert arrangeur merci mille fois
continuer coûte
il nuit à faire rêver merci de votre
invitation merci mille fois on retrouve
cette émission en rediffusion 1 sur
l'antenne on la retrouve en replay aussi
bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux et puis
sur le site internet
rt france.fr merci à tous a très vite
[Musique]